good evening everybody and welcome to uh
the license committee meeting on the
19th of October this is being streamed
live on trafford's uh
webcast on YouTube
so introduce yourself I'm Simon Thomas
Council of flixton Ward Deputy chair of
the license committee I've got Council
of Brotherton and councilor butt on the
as the other members of the committee we
have all the legal officer and Licensing
officers in attendance and the applicant
and
uh representators as you recalled just
to
briefly on how this will sort of run
um
Allison licensing officer to outline the
application
and they'll go through it uh there are
two here so there may be
two speakers on that then I will ask the
applicant Mr Dean to uh
sorry Mr Oliver Miss Dean to to
bring forward their reasons for the
application calling a witness we will
then have the opportunity should we need
to to question what you've said then
we'll ask the representators I believe
there's two of you yeah in all cases
when you're speaking if you can press
the
button that says mike your mic will
light up red
and then you'll be able to hurt that's
it but turn it off at the end of the
wise we won't be able to hear everybody
uh then we'll ask you to speak again
I don't know if you've got anybody wants
to speak first or second if you don't
speak over yourselves makes it again
easier for us to get a picture and we
may ask questions of you okay from then
we will give opportunity for both
parties to summarize and we'll ask you
to go back outside while we deliberate
uh once we come back
um we'll give you
the decision the reasons for it as far
as you can and then it'll be confirmed
in writing for within four five days of
the hearing is everybody clear on on how
we're going to do it okay
um so therefore agenda attendances as of
outlined who's here and item two
application for the grunt of a new
premise license under Section 34 License
Act 2003 uh beyond the trees ashburton
house Trafford Park Road Trafford
traffic Park m17 1bn we can
I see licensing officer if they would
outline the application thank you good
evening chair and the license committee
um
this matter is um regarding a premise
license and that is required in respect
of any premises where it is intended to
conduct one or more of the four
licensable activities these bring being
the sale of alcohol the supply of
alcohol regulated entertainment and the
provision of late night refreshments
this application was submitted by kayat
steinart Levy LLP on behalf of v g v e
Limited in respect to beyond the trees
ashburton house Trafford Park Road
Trafford Park Manchester m17 1bn
the licensing Authority is satisfied
that the application has been made and
all procedures correctly followed
the application applicants has applied
for a new premises license for the
following activities plays indoor and
Outdoors films indoors and Outdoors live
music indoors and Outdoors recorded
music indoors and Outdoors dance indoors
and Outdoors like music dance indoors
and Outdoors and alcohol on and off and
on a Monday to Sunday and 24 hours and
the opening hours being 24 hours
it's been established based on the
conditions in operating schedule
attached in appendix a that the hours of
the external event space are the
following
all regulated activities Monday to
Sunday 11 o'clock to in the morning to
um 10 30 in the evening the closing time
of external area Monday to Sunday 11 in
the morning till 11 at night
and there has also been agreement with
the police in relation to the first
floor internal space and this was um the
informal agreements but we are satisfied
that that the procedure was fought the
correct procedure was followed within
the correct time and that was agreed in
Sunday to Thursday regulatory regulated
activities including alcohol sales
permitted 10 a at 10 a.m till 4 opening
hours 10 a.m till 4 30 A.M
um Friday to Sunday regulated activities
including alcohol sales permitted times
10 a.m to 6 and 6 a.m and opening um
hours 10 a.m to 6 30 A.M
this application has been referred to
the licensing subcommittee during the
consultation period 10 representations
were received against the grants of the
application
nine of these representations were from
residents attached as appendix day and
one was from Peter bellfield who's
currently sat next to me of
environmental health attached at
appendix C
um a meeting was held on Wednesday the
12th of October with the applicant and
some residents following on from me a
meeting a number of residents have now
withdrawn their representations
the members of the subcommittee have
details of these withdrawals as well as
the noise management plan and residence
information which has been supplied with
the applicant
by the applicant
the subcommittee is asked to consider
the application and the representation
of all parties and make its decision in
arriving gets its decision the
subcommittee must also have regard to
the relevant provisions of the national
guidance and its own statements of
Licensing policy and the reasons should
be given for any departure
the opinions open to the subcommittee
are want to Grant the application in
full on the terms and conditions
contained within the application to
include any applicable mandatory
conditions
two to Grant the application but
modified to such an extent as considered
appropriate to satisfy any relevant
representations and promote the
licensing objectives or three to reject
the application
that is then the end of the mass summary
and of the application unless the submit
committee have any questions for me at
this stage
thank you
thank you Mr bellfield would you like to
add
um thank you Mr Bell Peter bellfield
um environmental health officer for
regulatory services at traffic Council
and just to
um expand a little
um I did initially put forward a
representation
um with concerns in respect of noise
nuisance from the external areas of the
premises
um the representation wasn't in relation
to the noise from the internal aspects
of the application which has not been
found to have been of any concern and
there have been temporary event notice
uh events run through the spring and
summer
um which have resulted in some
complaints
um I've spoken directly with the
applicants
um and also I've received the noise
management plan
um to explain how nice emanating from
the external areas which have been
subject to complaint can be managed and
the document is quite a detailed uh
documents and um
I I feel
um as a
reassured that um the issue of noise can
be managed
um therefore I have withdrawn my
representation subject to uh the
operating schedule which has been agreed
with the conditions uh relating to the
timings for events on the external areas
and also other conditions relating to
noise from inside the premises
so
um at this stage
um I don't have any objection to the
license being granted on those terms
thank you thank you Mr Belfield do we
have a copy of the Knowledge Management
plan
think of something I've seen it but
I just want to point out no no I just
want to what page we are
blender
yes please
and so that's the noise management plan
and then that was the summary of a
meeting a meeting that took place with
the residents okay
[Music]
bear with a second
question
uh just wondering whether there'd been
any comments from the neighboring
burrito from the from the council or
uh from the Council of it yeah
just to answer that I have been liaising
with my colleagues in Salford city
council to advice of the application and
also to update from the outcome of the
meeting are held with the applicant as
well okay thank you
okay
um Mr Oliver Miss Dean if you'd like to
excuse me submit your statements hi so
I'm Sam I'm the managing director and
owner of GBE which is the engineering
company on the site at ashburton house
um this is my partner Tash who's the
general manager of six trees which is
the restaurant and bar that we opened 18
months ago first of May 2020.
um wanted to explain first a little bit
of the concept of the venue so we built
a job in lockdown at the moment it's an
all outdoor space with a large decking
area that initially was a destined just
to be a Barn restaurant but the longer
we're in lockdown it grew and grew so
we've now got a large space and
we've been asked to the whole events
birthday parties things have got a
little bit bigger and bigger and we
decided last year that we were going to
use a series of tens to do some data
collection on the space to see whether
it was worth expanding moving into the
building and using some of the outside
space so at first I think something to
note here is that the events that we put
on were not our initial Direction and
plan that we wanted to do we did
initially have a six week book in which
Indigo Brewery to do an outside like
beer festival for local you know normal
sort of stuff and it fell through
because of the tens application so we
ended up finding the only things we
could book were more music events which
was not the direction we plan on taking
there was more post-covered generation
of Revenue keeping things coming when we
were quiet weekend through that process
we have worked with the police and with
environmental health
um John Lloyd from the licensing police
has come and set up an egress plan with
us and and worked on how we make safety
aggressive barrier off the roads in
certain places so I think that was
mentioned in somebody's representation
and that was put in place by the police
licensing officer who didn't block bus
stops and and other I mean it is but he
decided that that was the best way to
egress large numbers of people so we
kind of worked on that follow their
guidance
um we have been working hard to try and
figure out the direction we wanted to go
and the the main reason for this license
application was for the indoor space at
the moment as soon as it gets to this
time of year it gets very cold and we
struggle to operate a restaurant only
outside so the main the main guts of
this was to get us Insight of an inside
dining room and an extension to our
current bar and restaurant
I think in doing this and and and having
these activities go on we've definitely
learned it's been a sharp learning curve
for us I'm an engineer my engineering
company runs every day that's my core
I've never worked in Hospitality so
there's certain things we've learned
about who we want to work with and who
we are what to work that have come up uh
name and specifically three events that
we spoke to Peter about the first 14th
and 28th of May which were too loud we
we said there was a mistake on our part
the people that were involved who hired
the space since been banned and will
never be allowed to return and we know
that from speaking to the other
residents these were the the main causes
of concern because and we we admit that
was a mistake on our part they will not
be coming back
um this is partly why we volunteered the
noise management plan to say that we you
know we want to respect we want to be a
main part of the community the direction
we're going for we've got photo studios
we've got recording studios we've got a
lot of community activities that we want
to put on and your guide is in that
direction which was in our original
business plan and it was more means to
an end to have these larger scale music
events to get us through you know this
past year uh one thing that has been
confirmed in the start
um which I think was one of the main
causes for concern and the
representations was how people have read
the initial application that it was for
24-Hour outdoor activity now that is not
correct that was never what we'd asked
for we'd asked to reduce the hours to
half past 10 and anything beyond that
time was for in internal I think when
you read it it doesn't really very clear
we did ask Katie at the licensing office
to send that out and make that clear so
we hope that's kind of made you know
people understand now what we're
applying for we're not expecting to be a
24-hour license outside uh disturbing
that's definitely not what it is
um I'd like to First then move on and
look at the representations from the
responsible authorities
so
we've addressed this we've been working
with the responsible authorities through
these tenants we've worked with the
police with environmental health to try
and figure out you know how best to run
a successful and and smooth business
without having effects
um at the moment no representations have
been put in from licensed Authority
child safety or the fire service we have
had the fire service in to look at the
plans and they're totally happy there
was no official rep put in by the police
however I did as mentioned have an
informal conversation with John who I've
been John Lloyd from licensing police
who I've been dealing with throughout
these tennis process to talk to them
about what we wanted he'd mentioned the
way that it said 24 hours was sixth
Street's license a secondary opens at
seven and the latest we wanted was six
and we would just put 24 he said is that
detrimental to your business and part of
your plan we said no not at all we don't
plan to be open every day all the time
it just gives us the flexibility to do
events here and there on different days
that we need he said well if you take
that away because that has a lot
dumbbells ring in if you take that away
and
tweak a couple of things here and there
that we agreed to he was happy he didn't
put a representation in
we then also
had a representations from Peter
environmental health and we invited him
down for a conversation kind of talked
about our plans talked about the things
and again it seemed to come up that this
24-hour outside was too you know loud as
a concern which was again the way that
the solicitor submitted the license
request we confirmed some of that
tightened up some of the terms
pertaining to the outside space to make
sure that in no event we can go beyond
times and then we said we would
volunteer like an in-depth noise
management plan we had been working with
different companies and we now feel like
we've found the the right and
responsible of course at home company
for any events that do move outside
which should be massively reduced with
the PA type music this you know in our
normal operations having the inside
Space means that people who want to book
that we can now Force into the inside
space and have any loud music contained
like a normal premises would
um the outside space is lucky we want to
do things we build Ice Rinks at gve for
summer want to put ice rinks on grottos
at Christmas we want to do beer and food
festivals I think that was our main plan
was to feeling like a big Community beer
and food festival type things is not
geared mainly towards music but more
towards using the large outside spaces I
feel like the Beer Garden
um I think from the results of our
discussions and clarification on the
licensing
um with the noise management plan that
was Peter withdrew his representation so
at the minute we don't have any
representations from responsible bodies
and
are present
um
so it was that was our first aim um we
then like to address the the residents
um we did after receiving the
representations and would like to note
that we receive noise complaints after
the first 14th and 28th of May
um we took that seriously we banned
those sound people from attending again
we spoke to others we did still have a
number of different sound providers we
tried to put a structure in where we
were bringing the noise down and had
some noise management levels put in and
I think most people would agree that
compared to those events it was reduced
maybe not canceled but reduced we've
since had more detailed sound map been
done to work on the levels that could be
upgraded and again I would stress this
is not something that would be going on
weekly in our future plans we did hold a
residence meeting on the 12th of October
um it was invited from the licensing
officer to everyone to come and have it
to speak to us I think three people out
of the nine attended and of those three
people or three were happy with the
conversations that we had and were
overdrawn their representations
um we were pleased to be given that
opportunity because we were able to walk
around you know let them see what we've
been trying to build it's a self-funded
project we've been doing 90 Plus hours a
week and putting every penny for our own
money so we were able to tell them more
of the story and let them see who we
were rather than having the connotations
of some loud music events kind of affect
the way it was viewed
um we would like to
briefly I think I'll say I think I
mentioned before the things with the one
of the representations because I've
looked at everything in detail we've
read everyone and taken everything on
board
um I mentioned about the maps and the
street views of the I think one of them
detailed blocking bus stops and and
certain things so traffic
um this was not quite correct and this
was agreed with uh John John Lloyd from
police licensing that how he would like
us to approach it so this this was on
the guidance of Licensing
um we I don't know if everyone has
received because we did produce a very
very detailed noise management plan
which has a full complaints procedure
again as I say from the 28th of May up
until the license representations came
in we didn't have any contacts at the
venue no nobody's called us nobody's
wrong with us so we thought we'd dealt
with the issues nobody spoke to me or
sent me an email if you may have gone to
the council but we didn't receive that
until that end point so in in our noise
management plan there's a detailed
complaints procedure we would have a
mailing list so that whenever we go live
on any event again much reduced in
scheduling there would be a direct
contact with ourselves and the sound
team that if there is any issues it can
be dealt in real time live rather than a
buildup of annoyance over time but again
our main objective was the to completely
eradicate any any cause of news or need
for complaints uh we'd also hope that
the residents
but we want to run a successful business
and be an asset to the community we
don't want to be a source of nuisance we
don't want to be you know something
that's a Noisy Neighbor complain and we
want to operate in a way and we would
hope that people can come and enjoy what
we're trying to create what what's
happened over the last 12 months
detailing certain noise at the weekends
is not the main plan of our business so
we would hope the license would allow us
to proceed move things inside that have
loud noise
as a conclusion
um
the the question that was really brought
forward is whether the license of
activities saw can be conducted during
the hours saw in accordance with the
operating schedule uh without
undermining the the licensing objectives
is our view that through the noise
management plan the the changes of some
of the terms and
um that the stuff we put forward in the
plan that the answer is yes we can
um it's also the review of the
responsible authorities is yes with the
with the withdrawal of all the
representations and we would like to
respectfully suggest that the
responsible authorities are the experts
on this and their opinion will be duly
weighted we are also aware of all the
representations from the residence
committee and the responsible Authority
um has always had their concerns you
know as top priority so if if the
responsible authorities are satisfied we
hope that this is a reassurance for the
residents
um also we are committed to to what we
put in the noise management plan and
being in direct communication you know
and hopefully becoming friends and you
know being able to be there as part of
the community we do not want to you know
have any barriers we want to be there to
you know just to serve everyone Salford
keys or that area we were living in the
green rooms for the last year you know
to be close to the area so we want to be
part of that Community we don't want it
you know draw a divide in a barrier
um we were therefore
think that overall
um we would be able to reach an
agreement that yes we are capable of
upholding the the licensable objectives
and we've been pleased to work with the
licensible authorities and with the
residents through this process and we
are here to answer any questions and try
and appease any further concerns and and
create relationships rather than what it
was
thank you thank you very much any
counselors wish to ask any questions
Council thank you
have you kept an incident log take it
from in the past an incident log in
regards to any issues that have come up
that perhaps uh have needed to be
recorded
uh We've we've the if we've got any
events that have uh security team
required then the security team have on
our premises their own incident logbook
that they they fill in at the end of any
events I think so far we have owned
we've had
sort of 11 out of the 12 tens we went
through this year so of those number of
events we haven't had any major
recordable incidents uh was it was not
an everyday situation so we've not had
any incidents recorded now in regards to
the the complaints procedure that we we
didn't have any official complaints
besides an email from Peter we haven't
had any official contact from a
residents
just a couple free on your house on the
specific ten events over the past year
was also attendance fixity of that
uh the
when we were applying to the tens so the
the lice the current license and the
tenants would hold 4.99 each I think the
highest attendance we had at one event
over the whole period was about 950.
externally externally okay
um General operation I think we had
another one at about 700 and everything
else was about 500.
um obviously the community events that
you you've described going forward like
the ice rink in this life there will be
music at these events obviously there
has to be
how are you gonna
monitor the level of the music
um I think if there was an ice rink it
would be contained in inside an outside
Marquee I think
something that we noted in the noise
management plan was that there are
external speakers on the building that
we put in for the six trees bar and
restaurant uh I expect those with done
work at University where it was using
sound as like a barrier from the traffic
so we're right out on the round about
that kind of pointing towards the road
to kind of give like a barrier the way
that they're set up there they are
absolutely not possible to reach anybody
anywhere near the sofa Keys area where
we've had their operated all day every
day and they they're not a cause of
concern and people putting the noise
management along we've discounted that
the the main issue that has caused the
concerns is for outsourced PA systems
being large sound systems with like
heavy base spins and stuff like that for
an event such as ice rinks and and more
community events this is not required
they're not going to be on site we have
an in-house system that we we've for the
first year we directed everyone to use
that and as we've got more popular and
the events got bigger people are wanting
to you know push as far as they can go
so we've been trying to get a balance of
being able to provide like a concert
worthy experience without being a
nuisance and we've been working through
we have been doing sound checks on it
since the first three complaints where
we left the sound company in charge of
it and they did not follow what we'd
instructed so now we do have sound
testing we were sound testing from the
green rooms in in Media city and it's
kind of a regular hourly check that is
performed during the process again that
is there's a in the noise management
plan it states we have a company that
comes out who runs the sound system and
they that wasn't that wasn't just the
green rooms was it this uh you've taken
another site as well it wasn't just a
degree rooms in the noise yeah
everything the noise management plan
States now that we've received
representation mostly like I think all
but one of the representations within
the Heart Building yeah we chose and
we'd moved into the green rooms being
the closest as far as the profiles and
it seems that we've probably got more
defense from the building directly
between so we've said now we've got
evidence
oh sorry the Peter did a noise from
reading the in the noise management
noise
you have do you have two sides for your
sound checks we do now when we send out
the mailing lists to local area for
people who want to be signed on we will
build up and make sure but again I think
the sound levels in the sound map are
considerably dropped from the already
reduced levels that we're operating at
so there's been a reduction in there
from what we were operating in the
second half of the summer because I
think the the first ones were way too
high the the ones more recently have
been in and around kind of the
borderline of what is and isn't
acceptable and now we've reduced it
further still so there shouldn't really
be any audio effects over yeah I mean if
it was the interior noise I'd expect to
have a cut off the sound cut off when it
research and decibel level yeah
outside I understand it's very difficult
to do that because it's something that
we we've been looking into
um our sound provider I think have
provided sound equipment for other
spaces in the Manchester area who have
got an outside space and they have
talked to me about
implementation of technology that can
have a cut off for outside obviously it
doesn't it wouldn't make sense to do
that we didn't own any of the equipment
that was in there for the temporary
event notice events that are kind of
more for us to figure out whether this
was the direction we wanted to go
um
they said there is stuff that we could
look at further that also says there's
budget for more soundproofing changes of
things but the main thing is that we're
not getting audio sound over in in the
affected areas and we're happy to reduce
it to that level okay thank you
[Music]
okay uh we'll move on and
um
I've got Ms Malcolm Melman is that
and sorry um it's Fiona last day I'm
going to speak first
you're most likely yeah and Miss
Mountain okay
that's fine if you'd like to make your
presentation thank you
all right so my name is Fiona letny
um I've lived on sulfur keys for 18
years and then Media city specifically
for over 10.
um
and
um
I think what we're trying to say is that
in terms of the and we totally
appreciate the um the reasons why you're
doing this and also
um the way that you have
um you know attempted to alleviate the
issues
and we have absolutely no objections to
what's going on internally inside the
the buildings that as long as they can
be you know soundproofed and whatever
it's no problem with that in fact when
one of us made a comment earlier to say
that if we didn't hear
it's then we wouldn't have any
objections but the problem is we do hear
that the sound and even though you you
know you made
um quite a lot of changes after around
about May time
then the reason why I wrote the letter
and I think I started the letter saying
that you know it's the 17th of September
it's 4 30 in the afternoon and I've just
come back from a sort of a half day out
and it's warm I've opened the balcony
doors and I've all I can hear is the the
sound of what was going on at six trees
it's
it's not a decibel level issue
it's a nuisance an annoyance issue that
you've just got that underlying base and
um drums you've probably all been on a
train with um somebody sat next to you
that has got headset on headphones on
and the music is loud in their ears but
all you can hear is that annoying little
sound
that's what we hear that's what I hear
in the in my lounge and that's what's
not acceptable at all
um
as I say inside sound no problem you
know
there's no problem at all anything like
that outside is actually going to have
an effect and it's not just you know as
I say I know you've tried to kind of
make it a difference but it's not
actually solve the problem and it's that
just annoying background noise that it's
like a dripping tap and the fact that
you you know I know you're saying that
it's not 24 7. and that's fine but
at a weekend when I want to have peace
and quiet in my lounge with my balcony
doors open I don't I don't want to be
hearing that constant from uh what did
you say 11 o'clock in the morning to 11
o'clock at night I mean that is just I'm
sorry it's not acceptable and that's the
bet anything else
then you know no no objections but
there's no evidence so far and I
appreciate as well the um the noise
management
um report and that kind of thing but
there is no evidence to say that what
you've done so far has actually solved
the problems that we have and the where
um if there was a situation as an
example so Jubilee weekend
um which I think is was in June
um and
there were we were meeting as a as a
residence outside down you know outside
by the canal we'd arrange that and we
came from various buildings and various
Heights of the level and and everybody's
kind of saying
glad to be down here because up there
the noise is unbearable
um actually downstairs which is being
blocked by all the various walls of
Coronation Street and all the rest of it
in between times you know it was
actually there was less being outside
less noise than there was upstairs even
with the the window shut it didn't need
the windows open to actually hear the um
the sound unfortunately I'm sorry you
know to
um to say that but but it's just not
acceptable to to have the outside noise
as I say inside no problem
um
and I'm I'm sure yeah I think that's
probably said as much I don't know
whether Michelle you want to
fill the gaps in if I've missed anything
hello I'm Michelle Milkman good evening
everybody
um one of the things to say is the
buildings that media City kind of don't
they don't absorb the noise they kind of
refract the noise so it kind of
kind of bounces off each other
so something that you can think is quite
a long way away it actually sounds very
very close because you can hear the boom
boom boom boom boom for 12 hours in our
homes with the windows closed it's just
not acceptable we shouldn't have to hear
it full stop
um
yeah and also as vienne says the higher
up the building the noisier it becomes
DVD weekend on the ground floor you
couldn't hear it at all went home boom
boom boom where's his windows closed and
we just it's just not fair to make us
live with that noise
at all
um so yeah we've kind of object to any
outdoor live music or non-live music
that involves putting a PA system in
we just don't want to hear it and we
shouldn't have to hear it it's not there
that's it for me
okay before we come to question you
believe we've got a letter
from a resident that needs to be run out
yes I think one of the residents
couldn't attend that consolation yeah
one of the residents couldn't attend
tonight so she's asked for a letter to
be read out do you have the letter
to hand I think I've got to if right I'm
happy to read it out if
[Music]
um dear committee members further to the
above application in respect of beyond
the trees please accept our
representation we live in The Heart
Building Media city and have done so
since 2013. this area of Salford Keys is
said to be a place that puts people at
the center a place that works for
everyone it cares for the needs of
everyone who lives works and visits with
three kinds of neighborhood living
working and Leisure the area is
dedicated to having well-being as a
priority
the application indicates that the
applicant is requesting a 24-hour
license for the following activities
both indoors and Outdoors namely
provision of players films live music
recording music and dancing and all
things similar to these and all with the
supply of alcohol we understand that
noise can be considered to be part of
everyday life but the noise issues that
would be generated by these 24
activities has the potential to
unreasonably and substantially interfere
with the enjoyment of a home at an
invasion of the right to peace and quiet
Salford cases Awards side City made up
of popular residential area integrating
with commercial and leisure activities
the activities at these premises already
present noise nuisance on a number of
occasions especially to the residents
that live in those buildings where the
trajectory of the sound is unimpeded
especially the bass sounds in
consideration of the above may we please
request that you decide to refuse the
24-hour application Yours Faithfully Kim
Barnes
thank you learning the councilors have
any questions for residents
yeah
no um I've just got one regarding the
the meeting that was between the
residents and
beyond the trees excuse me
did any of you attend to meet the
meeting here
no we were given probably I think it was
about three or four days notice and I
was in London on business so it wasn't
it wasn't a load to loaded the reason I
ask is that the three the three
residents have seem to have withdrawn
their
um
representations as by the by is just a
statement of fact
in in cases like these as residents and
this is directly directed at you
would you be prepared to work with
the owners would be on the trees and in
in region a solution to this or do you
think
that that is beyond that
my my concern is and I accept that you
know in the um noise management plan
that you know phone numbers have been
given and that and that kind of thing
as I understand it each each time one of
these events is put on there is a third
party that is going to be
um in charge of the sound and my concern
is that every time we are dealing with a
different organization and somebody will
be pushing it just a little bit further
or whatever I mean at the moment with no
evidence that they've found a a solution
to the
um the the sound levels because on the
17th of September which I think was the
last time that they had a uh an event
then that wasn't
um
uh yeah it it was at an unacceptable
level and we just I'd rather
not have to deal with anybody I don't
have to keep ringing or to keep you know
because the the sound level because I
can't see that what they're expecting to
happen outside with a thousand people
with with all that you know
um that music that it can be at any
level that we can't hear it
the the other issue which it can't be
controlled I think is that the um the
atmospheric conditions so if the wind's
in a different direction or or whatever
then you can actually have it better or
worse
um and that can't be controlled so from
our perspective still that nothing
outside is is the the
um you know the third one that you were
talking about was refusing the
application to the outside I'm not
worried about we're not worried about
the inside
um but outside I just can't see that
that can be controlled to a level
um other than that they're doing on
their the the norm you know the
situations that you have at the moment
when there aren't events on
then no we don't hear that and that's
fine but it's when you're putting events
on that's we can hear it
okay thank you uh well any further
questions does anything come to like
I forgot now okay all I need to do now
talking to yourself if you could just
give us a summary a couple of minutes
somebody of what you've heard tonight
and give us
like an addendum to your application I
will come to the residence after that
for you to give us a quick two-minute
summary of going forward thank you
so I think probably the most important
thing would be to address what you just
mentioned there and the application for
the indoor outdoor at the point we did
discuss with Peter bellfield at the
point of application by law we can't put
restrictions on outdoor it's by the law
we would have to put the the license in
be granted if there was a problem we've
already spoke to PE he could then come
and condition the license to ban any
outside PA systems or such but we can't
do it at the point of application
so we as we mentioned probably maybe
skipped over a bit briefly in having the
outside space granted with a with a
license would allow us to pursue more
what we wanted to do which was events
away from PA system live music stuff
that was doing 10 11 of those week and
week out was not what we wanted to do
but it was the only bookings we could
secure on temporary event notice we've
got to apply for in not got a license
have got a license can we do it people
wanted to come in
places that wanted to do longer
installations we work with the people
who do the Camelot scare fest come into
our bar they they want to do a big hike
production with us of like outdoor kind
of interactive and we also mentioned the
shindiga that was going to be a beer
Focus beer and food festival so it's
outdoor not no focus on music no focus
on 10 hours of late night constant drum
drum drum on the window sort of Music it
would be like a more chilled out
Community beer and food festival
barbecues multiple food sellers we can't
do that on temporary event notice
because we can't secure like a six-week
booking so the reason we want the
outdoor is to move away from that and
use the large space we've got to do more
community-led events so the only way
we're going to get that is to be awarded
the license and then put those terms in
to work with you that if there is two or
three over the year with music that we
can get those levels to not be disturbed
we are not planning to go we've got a
license every Saturday 10 hours of music
that is not what we plan we did also
discuss because we booked in sort of 10
events when we didn't get the shindiga
brewery we were booked in 10 different
things through the summer giving them
all the same terms by the end of it we
were like we don't want to go this long
we don't want to go this late between us
because it was not us it was other
people we were saying Beyond nine
o'clock you know for the outside space
is late enough it goes dark we were
speaking to now the one appointed sound
person who's got friends of ours now are
the only people who are allowed to
supply outside sound so it's not a
different person every time they've got
our best interests at heart they're
working with us we've now said after
that last one on the 17th it's our time
providers or nobody else so we now do
have that control back and uh it was
kind of more
a push to to bring those hours reduce
the hours and I think our lives and said
not 11 it was 10 and we said anything
like that wouldn't be online they told
us that at night when the weather
changes it goes dark like you mentioned
the sound then behaves in a completely
different way so what we're checking all
through the day will change later on in
the evening we wanted to really push
that that our plan isn't to get the
license and then do 10-hour outdoor loud
PA systems every day so we can do use
the outside space for other stuff we
want to do Halloween scare fest we want
to use the massive space that we've got
to do like interactive Community stuff
if the whole outside is taken away we
can't do that so we're kind of asking
for the chance to prove
that when we're not coming to be that
nuisance and hopefully we've put in all
the plans and all the people at this
stage we can appease your concerns and
work with you to make sure that we do
not disturb you at all we don't we don't
want to have any reason for you to call
it's not like here's a number callers
will answer for feel like it we want to
work directly with you to appease these
concerns and stop any nuisance
altogether
thank you
um
would like to sum up
uh do I need to sum up what can I
respond to
me
okay
[Music]
yeah sure
um that's all well and good in theory
but if you don't get the events then
you'll need to talk look at Alternatives
in your alternative this might be what
we've had for the last year
so this is all kind of theory you talk
about
um
kind of
kind of in the best interests of six
trees but it's not in the best interest
of the residents to have live outdoor
events because we can hear it so we
still object to that
um and also you talk about community
events what community of events I
haven't seen any community events to
days so you know you've had a whole year
and a half to have community events and
be part of the community and that hasn't
happened yet so that's all again lots of
nice theories but we're not really
seeing any of these things into practice
which makes us very hard to be able to
trust
what's going to happen
and so far we haven't got a lot to basis
on so again just to say objects a kind
of outdoor live music events you can do
what you like inside as long as that's
fine
thank you
uh I will no no it's okay I'll you find
you're fine we just if you just speak to
him like that that no you don't you will
move across
the concern is the sound
it's the traveling of the kick drum and
the bass
is intentionally turned up loud
constantly by people around the world
we're not an eye enough naive enough to
realize what's going on with the music
and those events meant we had to close
our
windows and doors balcony doors and
actually put music on
to counteract it
all day now
my question is to you
as operators
but it will be rhetorical it will be a
rhetorical question what's happening
they won't be answering these days
debate my question is why do these
events with loud PA music
play the kick and bass drums louder
as they possibly can
which is damaging so their customers
hearing
people know that
sound Engineers know that and they'll be
all be going around with the decibel
counter yeah it's over 110 that's all
right
about frequency low frequencies bass and
kick
traveled as a long wave
and they go through the air and they hit
everything you don't hear the hi-hat or
the tambourine of the vocalist you hear
the bass and as a rule
you can almost pick out some of the
songs you might know
by
this that sound that's hitting you and
that's my concerns our concerns and I
think everybody who hears it
because it's intrusive it's like that
was hard but it's worse
we've had that song for the last hour
it was louder than that
in your home and that's the issue
for me
thank you okay thank you what we're
going to do now is excuse me I'll ask
you to just reach us out into the uh the
area and the committee School discuss
and then we'll invite you back in once
we've come to a decision on the
application and we'll give you the uh
result and the reasons behind the result
okay so we should call you back in in a
couple of minutes
[Music]